everybody what is going on welcome to
the 21st tkinter mega series tutorial RC
Cantor series can now legally drink in
the United States that's pretty
impressive so what we're going to do in
this one is we're going to add a support
for the other exchanges so the first
thing that we're going to go ahead and
do is if you look down in our animation
to tour our mission function rather
you'll see here that we have colors that
we plot with that's kind of a mistake
because we're hard coding these colors
in reality we have a light color in a
dark color that we're using but as we
add more exchanges and I had more time
frames and what we're gonna graph if the
time comes down the road where we decide
let's change our colors we're gonna have
a really hard time because we're gonna
have to go through and change all of
these colors now it's conceivable that
you could do ctrl H and you could hunt
for this specific you know 0-0 AAA or
whatever that's not the best way to do
it so now I'm gonna show you guys a way
that we can fix that so first let's go
ahead and let's just copy this one the
other one is 183 854 so come up to the
very very top here and basically we'll
just put it right here we're gonna have
dark color equals something and that's
our 183 and then we have light color
equals something which is 0 0 a 3 e 0
and then our dark color was 183 a 54 so
now we have dark color light color dark
colors that 183 so animates come down
here 183 is the dark color boom paste
and then we pastes light color and here
so now instead we have these variables
that we're using bring this up agree and
what has happened
uh-huh
up to the top here do we not put it yeah
we didn't put a pounce on there let's go
ahead and fix that one more time here
and I'm not sure I think volume we've
left hard-coded so volume means to be
dark color fine anime we felt where's my
mouse there it is
fill these in now let's go ahead and
call that dark color fancy that okay so
now what we're gonna do is add in the
actual exchange support so this block of
code is very specific to btc-e let's get
rid of here and now try and what try it
and the first question we're gonna go
ahead and ask is if the exchange equals
BTC dashi so that's the exchange we're
using well then hot diggity
this is the code we use so we take all
this code and tab over once and
everybody is a winner
now we have the question of bitstamp so
let's go ahead and we're gonna copy
basically all of this for the most part
so copy and then come down here enter
enter one over if exchange equals bit
stamp colon paste scroll up and bit
stamp the data link for bit stamp is
going to be HTTP corn colon www.pit.edu
affordable
trying to see what is any different here
utf-8 we are gonna load the data
I don't think pan or bit thin X or
bitstamp rather does the nonsense about
yes so they just straight up give you
the data okay they don't tell you bzz
USD all right so this it just starts
right away with dates and all that so
with bitstamp
we don't need this right redefinition of
data equalling data BBC USD so we can
just delete that for now and then we go
ahead and convert it to a data frame and
no problem and the only other question
is the buys and sells and actually you
know what I don't think I don't think
that bitstamp doesn't differentiate
between buys and sells
so actually we would change the data
here we're gonna go ahead and say volume
can stay as volume equals data amount
however we're going to go ahead and dot
apply whoops float and then dot dot to
list a dot clear is fine we don't have
buys and sells so we'll just do this and
I'm gonna do all three here to comment
all of that out and when we actually
plot
will do so we've got volume and then we
plot date we'll just get rid of one of
these so here plot date we're going to
do do we get date stamps so PLT got plot
dates we do all dates and then in here
we just plot data price fill between
again all dates that's fine and zero
volume face color that should stay the
same
instead of btc-e this is bit I can't
even remember from bit Stamper bit
things a bit stamp and they give us a
string data price from most recent so
that would be a zero we've set the title
and let's go ahead and save run and see
if that works out for us
so that's btc-e now we go here and
change that to bitstamp okay failed
because of timestamp so let's close this
come back here okay right so data let's
see there's is date so let's try that
one more time a great exchange bit stamp
same comes close out of this
let's do okay so you've got data date
stamp equals as type then we're gonna do
date stamps D equals data date stamp and
then dot two lists that we're not gonna
use all dates anymore we'll use date
stamps copy come down here and we're
gonna change that now to date stamp
state stamps let's try that again
Greeks change bitstamp still angry with
me
uh let's see so the problem was it's
date information that we're pulling
day seems day stamps
so data tastings and okay so we're going
to convert this it's probably coming
it's coming through as a string I guess
so will dot to apply int and actually
cut that and then we do and don't apply
it in there and then as types of time
there we go okay so now we've got the
bits and stuff a lot a little bit more
conversions than I wanted to do but
bitstamp doesn't differentiate between
the buys and sells so it's kind of
problematic and then they're just you
know they're API feeds data a lot in a
different way than when btc-e does so
that's what's kind of annoying when you
don't have normalized data they're all a
little bit different so you've got to
handle their data specifically how they
give it to you so anyway so now we've
got price and volume there we they don't
differentiate between buys and sells so
we can't really do that but we do have
volume and we do have the last price we
just don't know if those buy or sell so
um so we've got that let me see the
other thing let me go I see a book we
write okay so if you didn't notice when
we went to go run that our client logo
has shifted again or shifted off of what
it used to be let me go ahead and take
this we're gonna cut let's go to the
very very very very bottom here right
after self dot show frame and let's try
to stuff it down there at the very
bottom there we go okay so it was being
overridden and that was a problem so
anyways now we've got our logo back and
we're showing bitstamp and now we need
to add the other exchanges as well so
the other exchanges have their own
little quirks as well so we'll do that
and I think I'll save that for the next
video or hopefully will be a lot the
other next two exchanges in the next
video so stay tuned for that if you guys
have any questions or comments feel free
to leave them below let me go ahead and
get us back to the animation function
and scrolled down a little bit the code
will eventually find its way onto Python
programming done it just takes me a
while sometimes to put it up the code
but here's the first block of code
before the clear if you needed that if
something's going wrong that's the first
block and then I can scroll us down a
little bit down this is the second block
of code so if you need anything pause it
look at it figure out what you need
Susan 1080p so you should be able to
read that you just fine okay so anyway
next video will either probably
hopefully the next two exchanges and
then we'll actually get into plotting
candlesticks and all that kind of stuff
so out of this kind of nitty-gritty
nonsense so it states you for that
question comments below as always thanks
for watching